- Am I gonna get a nice mesh thing?
- Um,
you'll have some mesh.
- Something.
Oh no!
(upbeat music)
- High school fashion, baby!
- I really don't know how high
schoolers dress these days.
- What's a septum?
- Aaahhh.
Ahhh!
- They're doing things
that I still to this day
am not confident enough to do.
- Are you ready?
- Dayum!
We have four amazing
diverse high school girls
who sent in their dream
vision of how they want
their high school male
counterparts to dress.
- And to bring their visions to life,
we've brought in a designer!
Who's gonna make us all hawt.
Oh yeah.
- Nothing like a bunch
of 30 year old men
getting dressed up by little girls.
(upbeat pop music)
(cowbell rings)
- It's high school
makeover time!
(quirky music)
- How do high schoolers
dress now?
- I dunno, they dress cool.
Like Jack.
Come here Jack, get over here.
- They just where a lot more patterns
but everything's like tight.
- This is what high schoolers look like.
He's got the cool hair
that Ned's tryin' to have.
- It's a lot of like high waisted
hip type short things.
- He's got this like, half tuck.
Every time I try to half tuck my shirt
I look like a moron.
(both laugh)
- They do like the button
all the way sometimes.
- They put things together
that I just don't understand
and I admire it in a lot of ways.
- I don't know, what are
these, old VHS tapes?
- [Jack] I don't know.
- You don't have to know what they are
because they're hot!
Explain to me how a cassette works, Jack.
Go sit down!
- Today when a trend happens
you immediately know it happens
because of the internet.
We didn't have that in the 2000s.
We had to wait a year.
By the time we wore it,
it was not cool anymore.
- Jack is proof that high
schoolers dress really well now,
at least the ones that
have the hair like that.
- (laughs) The way that
I dressed in high school
kind of existed up until like
(upbeat rock music)
two years ago.
My jeans were always way too long.
This was coming out of the days
where baggy jeans were cool.
I just didn't get the memo that
everyone else had moved on.
I wasn't cool enough to skateboard
so I wore the skateboarding clothes
and I then I wasn't
funny enough to be funny
so I put jokes on myself.
All the things that I wanted
to be but didn't know how to be
because I was an insecure young twat.
- My style in high school was a lot of
(quirky music)
baggy polo shirts.
I think it was because I was kinda skinny.
Like if I wore a tight shirt
I would just look like
a plucked chicken.
(chicken clucks)
Only recently after I got married,
where Ariel would kind
of help me find things
that she found more attractive.
So I wouldn't say I
truly became fashionable
until I was a 29 year old.
- Just last year?
- Yeah, it was last year.
- Oh, I was a geeky nerd.
I played french horn.
Played Magic: The Gathering.
It wasn't on brand for me to look good.
I dressed real funny.
I just dressed like outfits
were meant to be jokes.
It didn't seem like girls liked me
so I didn't wanna give 'em a reason to
(laughs) and it worked.
(crew member laughs)
I can say I succeeded
at repealing all women for
a long time in my life.
(french horn toots)
(upbeat electronic music)
- I was kind of dressing
in whatever I thought was stylish
which was highly dominated by a lot of
Justin Timberlake going solo.
I look back at my photos and I'm like,
"Kill it with fire."
I did not look cool.
I wore a lot of scarves on t-shirt.
A lot of man jewelry, one
ring, one bracelet, dog tags.
Dog tags were huge.
We were all nerds in high school
and I think in the end
we just wanna look cool.
So I know these girls are gonna
wanna get their hands on us.
- Hi, I'm Andrea.
- Hi, Andrea.
- What's up Zach?
- This is how she says hello to people.
I'm gonna try and lock that in.
- Leah's glasses match her necklace.
This is great.
- I love her hair color.
Already a good sign.
- I'm gonna look at your
high school pictures now.
From the pictures I'm seeing,
baggy pants, baggy
shirt, baggy everything.
- Okay, I get it Vina.
I was baggy.
- Baggy, baggy, baggy, baggy, baggy.
- This sizing, these pants, the length.
- Look at these pictures.
Look at them.
- She smiling
but she hates it.
- Oh (laughs).
No, I was not ready for this.
- (laughs) Oh no!
- [Andrea] I'm not diggin' the shoes.
- I just had one pair of shoes.
- There are shoes for everything
but not one pair for everything.
- I really like the second picture of him
just admiring a glass cup.
- That was Thanksgiving.
- Why (laughs)?
- This is me on a plate.
- Wow Keith, there's so much going on,
like, I really don't know what to say
(Keith laughs)
at this point.
- When you walked in, whether
it's a good or a bad way,
you left me at a loss for words.
- Your clothes don't fit you well.
I guess they might have been
trendy during your time.
- Eh.
- It just looks like
you're trying to figure out
who you are but you don't really know.
- She's right.
- Ooh.
Yikes.
Tank top and jeans, flip-flop combo,
a combo that we don't need
to bring back into the world.
- Marley is so shady.
I love it.
- The deep V paired with the gray vest.
True icon.
- I always applaud accessorizing and you,
you went there.
- That scarf I would just like,
don't
ever
do that again.
- Sorry Marley.
- Yikes.
- I'm sorry.
(upbeat music)
- These looks that the
high schoolers brought are gonna be
really, really, really amazing.
- What my style is for
you is 80s rock and roll.
- [Roman] Sort of grunge direction.
- That's my style.
And I wanted to portray
my style onto yours.
- She wants rock and roll.
I can do this.
- Like, Cole Sprouse.
- Wait, Cole Sprouse from Zack and Cody?
I'm gonna live that suite life.
- He's very leather jacket
and like messy stuff,
messy hair.
- Zack's a bad boy.
- The style I chose for
Ned was pretty spooky
to be honest.
- Spooky?
- [Andrea] I really wanted
him to look straight out
of a Nylon magazine.
- She's gonna make me extra.
- We're gonna do some
oversized pieces, high waist,
maybe a belt moment--
- Oversized, high waisted
sounds like pajamas.
Am I gonna be wearing pajamas?
- Um, denim pajamas?
- Still trying to achieve
that artsy look for Ned.
- I can definitely stand
to be a little more artsy.
- All this hair is gonna
be brushed to the front.
I think hair says a lot about
how a person wants to look.
- So I guess my hair says that
I don't care about anything.
- Keith, the style we have chosen for you
is a more refined, minimalistic
street chic look.
- What?
There were seven adjectives in that.
- It still follows the current
trend of high school guys
but with a more refined grown up taste.
- You are probably gonna
be the most fashion forward
of The Try Guys today.
- Well that is not normal.
- A lot of avant-garde
is coming into trend,
brands like JW Anderson,
Ann Demeulemeester,
Rick Owens,
Dries Van Noten.
- Sure.
- The style I'm kinda looking for is more
an androgynous queer fashion as we see.
- Rainbow flag, right on.
- I wanted to have possibly more
of a masculine clothing type
but have like makeup and hair.
- With her look we are going all the way.
- Hmm.
- I don't know how open
Eugene is--
- I'm open.
- To dying his hair.
- Oh well, not that open.
(laughs)
Dayum.
- Are you ready?
I think I wanna have you try this on.
(quirky music)
- Wow, a plastic jacket.
- [Ned] Whoa, whoa,
whoa, easy.
- Yeah, a little wool moment.
- I'm gonna start describing
my clothes as moments.
- Everything is a moment.
- Oh my God.
I'm having a moment.
- [Zach] What's on the back?
- [Roman] More scorpions,
more scorpions.
- Wow, I'm a bad boy.
- (laughs) Kinda makes my
stupid outfit look like,
"Oh he's got a point here
he's trying to make."
- Yeah, it's pretty cool.
- Get the will of the
asian ancestors before you.
- I can help--
- We're good with little feet.
- Why do I feel like I'm
about to invade Normandy?
- This is cooler than anything I own.
- And this is not because
I need the glasses.
- No, this is strictly fashion.
- It's cause I want the glasses.
- [Roman] Exactly.
- [Zach] Oh, I'm into this.
- A little fundo tee.
- It has crosses on it.
- You know I'm Jewish, right?
- But we might not go with this one.
And I mean if we removed all of this...
- Dumbledore!
- I think I'm just a traffic cone
that tried to dress like a human.
This is what people wear.
- I've seen things like this in the store
but I'm just always afraid that my
(laughs) hairy body's gonna
poke out of it in weird ways.
- Some people like hair.
- Some people.
- It's a choice.
It's a moment.
- It is a moment.
Vina wants you to look badass.
- She wants everyone to look badass.
I just happen to be her
palette that she stuck with.
- Exactly.
- I'm excited for her vision.
Because I think any vision
is better than this.
- You need some help?
- No I'm good.
I'm just gonna
walk on outta here.
(laughs)
(bell rings)
Ned.
- [Ned] What?
- What'd you get on number 5?
- I'm not telling.
- Keith what'd you get on number 5?
- Danesha.
- This is a math class.
- Oh, shit.
(upbeat rock music)
- We're losing this?
- We're losing that.
- Old Zach
is dead!
- I hope you don't completely hate it.
He's bad boy but he doesn't seem bad
and I have no doubt
about you pulling it off.
(upbeat pop music)
- Welcome to The Suite Life.
(everyone laughs)
(upbeat rock music)
- Yeah.
- Wow.
You look like a bad
boy who lost 70 pounds.
- I'd give him my lunch money.
- Like old Zach is me versus
the guy she told you not to worry about.
- Nice meme reference.
- I love the jacket.
I love the shirt.
The rings are overwhelming to me.
- Is that a thing that I can start doing?
Cause I like this.
- I think Vina's version
of you rocks this jewelry.
- I'm still handling
the length of the pants.
- [Zach] I got hot ankles.
- You really Cole Sproused up.
Did Dylan die?
- No he didn't die.
- Who are these people?
- There are pieces in this outfit
that I either own or tried to own.
So like I'm on the right track.
- To being a high schooler.
- I look like the guy
that would make out with your prom date
which is a nice role reversal
cause someone else made
out with my prom date
in front of me!
- Wow.
Wait, I didn't know that about you.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Why'd he do that?
- That's horrible.
- Let's talk about this.
- This is a very realistic version
of a cool guy in high school today.
- I'm a bad boy.
Bad boy.
I'm a bad boy.
- Uh, we need to stop this now.
(bell rings)
- Hey Keith.
- Yeah.
- You wanna join the pen 15 club?
- Yeah, I love the penis club.
Have you ever been to like pen island?
Penis land?
(everyone laughs)
- I think Ned is gonna be horrified
in this look.
(Ned groans)
- Oh God.
Ah!
- We can nix the nose ring.
- No, no, no.
(Roman laughs)
(upbeat music)
Nose ring's essential.
- And he's gonna have black nails
because his style has a lot of angst but
I know he can pull it off.
(upbeat electronic music)
- School is meaningless.
(everyone laughs)
- Oh!
Wow!
- Oh
my
God!
- What?
(upbeat tango music)
You look great.
- From behind--
- Thank you.
- I don't know who you are.
I just know I want to sleep with you.
- [Ned] Get in line.
(Zach giggles)
- (laughs) What is this
attitude you've taken on?
- [Eugene] Hair is great.
The septum piercing actually looks
really good.
- Yeah, the coat is gorgeous
and like just the colors
across the outfit are
amazing.
- [Eugene] You look like a
really hot artistic lesbian mom.
- Snaps to that.
- If you went to high
school with me though
I wouldn't know what to do with myself.
- Let me be clear Zach, I would definitely
not be your friend.
- You do kinda suck now too.
- Oh yeah.
(everyone laughs)
- This is such a look I've never seen
matched with nail polish on
a guy and it's incredible.
- [Eugene] Every item you're
wearing your wife could borrow.
- I'm a trendsetter.
I certainly would never have
chosen this for myself but
now that I see it, I really like it.
I just can't wait to get into
Oxford and start my real life.
- (laughs) Oh God, you suck so much.
I've learned that you suck so much.
- I bless you and I respect you.
Class dismissed.
- [Zach] Nope, we've
still go two makeovers.
(bell rings)
- (sighs) Are you done yet Eugene?
- Done doing what?
- Breathing?
(laughs) "Are you done yet?"
"Done with what?"
"Breathing."
(Zach and Ned snicker)
- Alright, you ready to
get dressed up for school.
(upbeat music)
- I'm so ready.
- Honestly, you should feel badass
and cool.
- What?
The other guys are gonna be so jealous.
- I think you can totally pull it off
as long as you got the confidence
and you feel great in it.
- I think this look
deserves some extra credit.
(Ned laughs)
- Oh my God!
- Look at the custom belt!
- Wow!
- How is there Try Guys on that?
Was that you Roman?
- Of course.
- Roman!
- You are having an orange moment.
- [Keith] Do I look like
a sexy traffic cone?
- Yes!
- Yeah.
- You don't look like a traffic cone
but you would stop traffic.
- That was good.
- I've never seen
you wear boots.
Those pants are beautiful!
- Yeah, these pants
are amazing.
No, I definitely didn't
think I would like it.
- [Eugene] And do you?
- Yeah, everything about
this is pretty stunning.
- You look like a very
fashionable Japanese person.
(upbeat Japanese music)
- Yes!
That's what it is.
- Wow.
- Right?
It makes sense because this
is the most fashion forward
and Japan is always like three and a half
seasons ahead of us.
- This is just the coolest
version of yourself.
- Jack will you come back
to the stage please?
- Jack!
- How do I look?
- Honestly, you do pull it off.
- Yeah?
Fuckin' lit as shit.
(everyone laughs)
Is lit as shit a thing?
Cause that's great.
- This is a beautiful moment
and I just want us to all appreciate
that all three of us look
way better than Eugene.
- Yeah, Eugene looks terrible.
(bell rings)
- You know,
I know some really great ramen spots
if you ever want me
to show you sometime.
- Oh, I know ramen spots.
- Zachary have you ever read Hemingway?
- I don't read.
- Don't.
- First thing we're gonna do is take off
all these accessories.
Actually, those first.
Put those over there.
- Dressing androgynous
is such a beautiful thing.
- Pull the fishnets up over your shirt.
- [Eugene] Over the shirt?
- Having men wear things
that a typically feminine
person would wear
hopefully it will open
a new avenue of style
for him because he does
seem very confident.
(upbeat music)
- [Eugene] 'Cuse me?
Is this the nurses office?
- What?
- Because this look
is sickening.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Wow!
(Ned laughs)
What?
Huh?
Very like
entrancing.
I find it very beautiful
and I don't understand it.
- [Ned] Oh my God, you
have double ear piercings.
- [Zach] Now you're wearing
makeup but it works.
- [Ned] Also you have the giant boots on
and then your hair just goes straight up.
It's like your seven feet tall.
- Wow, look at that.
(laughs) Look at that!
- I can't be a bad boy
when I'm this little.
This is a cool jacket.
It's got some really great
details on it, the hood.
I'm torn on the fishnets on the leg.
- [Keith] Yeah, they're
high waisted fishnets.
- Do I look like
Tilda Swinton and Rihanna
had an asian baby?
- I feel the Tilda.
- I see a Tilda.
- You're having a Tilda moment.
- [Zach] You said it was
gonna be an androgynous look.
I expected it to be more foreign to me.
I think anyone could wear
that and pull it off.
- Uh, yeah.
In high school you try to stand out.
You're trying to define who you are
and you're trying to use your fashion.
You're developing your personality.
To have this strong of a look
is such a statement.
- For all those high school boys out there
ready to experiment.
You got four new looks to play with.
- And they only cost $30,000.
(everyone laughs)
- Shh.
Style is so individual
and is such a deep expression of oneself
that many times a lot people
say they don't have style
but I think it's just that
they haven't found it yet.
We were lucky enough to
find four young girls
who have found their style
and shared it with us.
- Throughout my life
there have been things
I wasn't confident enough to wear.
And that's not a high school Zach thing
that's just an always me thing.
And today has shown me
that that is a restriction
that I put on myself.
- Do it for how it makes you feel
and like how it affects your personality
cause maybe when you do
think outside of the box
you could be rewarded for it.
- I think it's all about
just surprising people
with how you look.
I was doing it with a negative way
but you could surprise
people by looking cool.
It's still just as effective.
- There's a lot of things
that we might be wearing
that you might not be
personally comfortable with
but someone out there is
and I think that's what's important.
- (laughs) If you're
not cool in high school,
if you don't dress like this,
that is okay.
But the fact that some high
schoolers think like this,
is amazing.
- Grab some of your friend's clothes.
Put 'em on.
See if you look hotter than them.
Jack, give me some of your clothes.
(everyone laughs)
- Schools out for summer boys.
- [Keith] Alright, I hate school.
- At the end of the summer I realized
the world hadn't changed.
I'd changed.
Freeze frame!
(upbeat pop music)